let's get at this ok where is its
appearance so so why is a factor in to
these guys maybe we could say people
like entertainment don't they right it's
like a basic human desire even the you
get any culture right any socioeconomic
status they're all crave entertainment
ok so that's something which has all you
could say a broad appeal I suppose ok
pop will you tell us yours okay i'm
gonna say free / cheap cuz it's not all
free but also i would get it something
else what's free I mean like what do you
mean is free okay so that's sort of um
that's sort of a subset of this isn't it
do you agree like it's economically
accessible okay but there's a flip side
to that as well ah it's free for the
consumers but who are the other people
who make this machine work not just the
consumers where all these videos come
from all the creators and producers
right which is why I said cheap now
let's just consider this actual I'm
going to ask you to research this letter
but just give me some estimates actually
think it costs to make let's say a
feature film feature film when you'd go
to the cinemas to watch well it's a
ballpark what do you think some least it
could cost the cheapest anything a
million dollars to get into box office
do you think sorry I start to get into
um like to actually be a mainstream
movie that you know could get worldwide
distribution that's the thing i'm gonna
ask rick anyway you're gonna eight
million i reckon it's it's sort of in
the close to tamp it takes i think one
minute is so like indie films right and
depends on how many locations you go to
your kind of thing i'm serious i don't
think a one-million-dollar feel a mess
was made by someone very exceptional
forget worldwide distribution
okay all right now wonder those that's
right eight million dollars ish what's
our upper ceiling do you think what's
the most expensive movie we know about
come in avatar your avatars and
Titanic's James Cameron I you just just
spending money everywhere I need gold
plated cameras you know um what do you
think how high does it go hundreds of
millions do you think I'm pretty sure
like the amount of CG that actor just
just hiring the actors that cost
millions of dollars right ok now let's
just compare that what's it cost to make
a video on youtube now i'm not going to
say it's free because it's not because
you need a few things can we get some
numbers what do you need to make a video
on youtube need a camera how much 100 is
a hundred reason book yeah let's let's
go this what we said before lower limit
was eight million so let's go let's be a
little adventurous what's a decent camp
500 I think that's pretty good okay what
else do you need you need some people
okay Sarge a murder uh you know so maybe
let's let's call it now this is kind of
weird right because what if it's just
you you can do a lot of stuff just on
your own right and what are you gonna
get i'm charging myself wait a second
okay so you know this is a question mark
really depends on what kind of stuff you
make you need anything else bothering
him you might you might kind of it might
kind of need the internet how much does
have cost yeah i mean how much in a year
say what's a mid-range babe what's that
that's like um it's like are you get
less than that every quarter let's call
another 500 okay so you look at a
thousand dollars plus depending on how
you people you're interested in how much
time it takes you right here do you get
what I was to hear before worldwide
distribution
people in any country can see that isn't
that astonishing you get that right
which is why I let's go there now shall
we okay now admittedly if you just have
a look at this front page right a lot of
it is produced by professional people
right and for a good reason haha look I
didn't even plan that um for a good
reason music videos are at least if you
measure by views they're the dominant I
after so the dominant species on YouTube
right why why is it music videos how
many times do you watch a music video
you're like I've watched it done I don't
need to watch this anymore I've seen all
the things i need to do that you put it
on repeat don't she if you really like
it well at least if it's a new song and
you kind of interested you listen to a
few times that's just one of you right
and that's how they get to doesn't show
you to you that's how they get to
hundreds of millions of views okay and
you also have justin bieber flans
playing play replay over and over again
so you can get any way now but other
stuff on here okay let's let's have a
look at you know freeze out one of my
favorites um I want the channel okay
look at this get this okay um almost
500,000 subscribers wow I wasn't the
intended effect almost 500,000 and I'm
going to call the regular viewers that's
what they'd be for TV show right um this
may million views and this just started
from a couple of brothers and they can
shoot they've got they've got some brews
this which is set up for it right and
I've got this worldwide audience right
it's astonishing okay so when we say
let's come back here
let me say free / cheap and it's really
both ways okay and that's that's huge
not to be underestimated possibly the
biggest one here let's get rid of that
selfie okay now these two parts I would
like you to do on your room mainly
because i want you to all to pick
different ones okay I'd like you to
select three sites so you can pick from
this list that we came up with if you
like or if you find another one that you
think is interesting and different go
for it okay pick three of them any three
and then I'd like you to contrast the
sites how they different why is it that
you know one hasn't been totally
destroyed by the other they've got it
there's gotta be some kind of
distinction between them and don't just
think of our features think about the
social aspect think about what kind of
people use this versus the people use
this versus well I think we know the
people use this right but then compare
and contrast them okay and lastly I want
you to describe for this whole category
of online multimedia story interview
what one of the benefits the result from
this we talked about a few of them
already but we've only alluded to most
of them okay so what kind of benefits
this is a social and ethical issue right
come for the producers come for the
consumers and if you want you can even
look at the company's people like say
machinima right that's a big channel on
YouTube that's a real company right it's
not just a bunch of guys sitting around
on it is a bit cool idea so companies
now increasingly are investing in
YouTube and YouTube want it okay so tell
me about the benefits that's enough if